what's going on guys the spoilers for my
hero academia chapter 294
are out and horikoshi has somewhat found
a way to include
yet another reveal in this arc in the
last few chapters we've had bakugo's
hero name reveal
we've had muriel's return best genius
still being alive
dabi being toyah and now to top
everything off
we've got the reveal of mr compresses
identity
and his lineage it really makes me feel
that harikoshi is trying to wrap up like
virtually all the existing mysteries in
this series
and it kind of makes me wonder you know
is a time skip gonna happen
sooner than we think just before we get
into the spoilers be sure to subs the
channel and remember
that every sunday on twitch i do a live
reaction to the official translations
which always has more details than the
spoilers
okay so the name of chapter 294 is the
last stage
which i think is a subtle reference to
mr compresses theatrical nature
and also the fact that the war arc is
coming to an end
the chapter begins with panels of
injured and unconscious heroes all
across japan
which includes hawks miraco mount lady
izawa
and endeavour if you saw the chapter
last week you'll know that endeavour
gathered all of his strength to give
gigantomachia a big punch to the face
but in the process it seemed that he's
used the last of his energy
as mentioned in a previous video
endeavour has been fighting literally
all day so it's a miracle that he's made
it this far
before finally passing out the manga
switches over to best genus
who is now able to focus all of his
energy on restraining
the different paranormal liberation
front members this is because
last chapter momo sedative finally
kicked in
and so this gives genus the opportunity
to focus on the other villains
with the sedative now working it's
definitely a blow to my momo traitor
theory
so i guess for the time being someone
irrelevant will go back to being the
main suspect
i'm going with invisible girl for now
but um who knows maybe it's
i don't know someone in class 1b who
knows at this point
anyway while all this is going on the ua
students are still
trying to protect best genus by fighting
off the black nomus
the spoilers say that these nomus have
now reached a level of strength that is
equal to the higher nomu which fought
against endeavour
so obviously the situation is really
tricky now
tenure tells bakago for the 100th time
to just stay out of the fight because
he's severely injured
and dynamite thinks to himself that
tenure was right but you know at this
moment he's so
injured that he can't even reply best
genus then begins to go on the offensive
and uses his steel fibers to squeeze the
villains extra hard
with the intention of making them go
unconscious shigaraki
spinner and compress are all victims of
this squeezing
and the manga briefly shows us a panel
of toga who is away
somewhere else running through a random
alleyway i
imagine that toga will make her
appearance very soon because when she
initially
left the villains to find ochako spinner
made her promise to return to them
so i think she'll join up with them
before the villains all leave
as genus continues to squeeze the life
out of them spinner makes a hilarious
face
whilst expressing his love for the other
members however
compress uses his quirk at the last
second to free his right hand
and then he compresses both spinner and
shigaraki
by using his quirk he's freed both
himself and the other villains
from these steel fibers that were
restraining them it almost sounds like
the perfect magic trick
which is something you'd expect from a
performer like this from the leaks we
have so far
at some point in this chapter congress's
mask comes off his face
which gives us a good look at him for
the first time he reveals that he is a
descendant of oji harima
who was described as one of the greatest
villains in history
harimah was a famous thief and was
previously seen next to all for one and
destro
back when gentle criminal was talking
about the most famous criminals
this means that the paranormal
liberation front have the successor to
all for one in shigaraki
the son of the number one hero in derby
the son of destro in redestro
and now they have a descendant of one of
the most famous thiefs to ever live
in mr compress a few chapters ago
congress mentioned that he was surprised
that another member of the villains came
from a famous bloodline
which was a big clue that he himself had
something to hide
whilst the spoilers don't confirm his
exact relation to oge harima
i imagine that congress is the son of
this villain but we won't know for sure
until the official translations come out
also just before i move on it's worth
noting that compress has basically the
same hairstyle
as oji harima himself honestly i've
never even thought about what mr
compresses hair looked like
like he always just wears the hat i've
never even thought about it um but yeah
seeing his real face and seeing his uh
and his seeing his hair
is definitely way different to what i
would have imagined the scene then
switches over to shoto vs toyotaroki
and they continue to blast each other
with flames with endeavour now lying on
the ground unconscious
toya isn't really interested in
continuing the fight anymore
and he tells shoto that there's been a
change of plans
dabby sees no point in killing his
brother at this moment
because if his father isn't awake to
witness it then you know what is he
doing it for
debbie unleashes a jet burn attack to
push choto away
and then he retreats back onto
gigantomachia's back
that last jet burn from toyo was enough
to burn shoto and just make him fall
back completely
which means that shoto endeavor bakago
and deku
are now all in really bad shape with
compresses identity now revealed
the chapter ends with him saying that
it's now time to begin the escape show
next chapter i imagine that we'll see
the villains just trying to get the hell
out of there
so let me know down below how you think
they're going to escape
i'd like to see your take on this down
below and remember check me out on
twitch this sunday
if you want to see my reaction to the
full chapter i have a video coming out
tomorrow on youtube
so be sure to keep a lookout for that
and until the next one
peace out